[Music]
are you
I've been sketching to see you I have
you really oh yeah okay I got a girl who
in two seconds this wasn't on camera but
Dave is going to make me a tattoo is
that right we'll see we'll see gotta
make sure it's good I drew a really
awkward one intentionally to see if you
would tell me it was bad oh my God that
would be the I wouldn't do it dude Maybe
a nail salon they can cut off my finger
and I'd be like it's crazy
great gosh we're here season three
season three season three is upon us
okay so during the events of book of
Boba Fett we saw that groco did elected
not to be trained by Luke I'm curious
how that affects his Force usage going
forward oh you asked the long
complicated questions I mean look
training with the force is like anything
simple right it takes trading and
discipline you must practice it and you
have to be dedicated to it so he's lucky
that he's not a teacher Luke had Obi-Wan
as a teacher and he learned some
fundamentals and he kept at those
fundamentals even after Obi-Wan died in
a new hope so by the time we met him in
Empire Strikes Back Luke had developed
his skills so if grogu maintains his
discipline and focuses on his training
he can still you know develop his
abilities but it's it's the focus of
training the dedication that makes all
the difference because we all have the
force in us we're all connected to it
the difference is you and I aren't
training right now and that's very
difficult to do as Qui-Gon mentions it's
not an easy life
when he talks a little Anakin about it
so you know he has abilities and he's
obviously talented and it's really up to
him what he's going to do with it going
forward
we'll just groggy at this point
I mean we said he was around three years
old so then I won't nail down a
definitive number because I will tell
you how long these series have been
going on and then you know it
thing and then we get into like this and
that and I have to use generalized terms
like this because I don't want to give
things away so you'll find out always
emotion is the future he's 50 years plus
15. no like Disney plus see I did that I
worked that in two what is at what age
does that species start talking
it's a good question I mean
I would suppose fairly young I mean we
don't know that he's not talking in his
own way you know and obviously he could
communicate with Ahsoka or she could at
least Divine from him some type of
communication so why do you want to see
that you want to see him talk yeah I
want to see his first word be dad or
whatever really what would his first
word be
we'll see I'm also curious because like
he obviously didn't really well maybe
early on but like didn't really grow up
with a species so it's like does he talk
like
the backwards riddles like Luke was
asking
well I'm just interesting because Luke
asks Sam during book of he talks like
that and then I'm like but if he's kind
of raised by Mando is he just gonna
start talking like man though and being
like this is the way maybe
I think your influence about here around
it's a good question basically you have
good questions if I say mythosaur you
say stop it can I say stop it you know
I'm not answering these things
[Music]
foreign